- Ja! Das sieht gut aus.
Diesmal schaffen wir das.
So schwer ist Kochen doch nicht.
Zwiebeln schneiden …
Das mache ich.
Du schneidest den Feta-Käse
in kleine Stücke.
- Alles?
- Ja, wir brauchen 250 Gramm.
Danach schneidest du die Tomaten
und den Schinken klein.
Und zum Schluss legst du alles
auf den Pizzateig.
Schau mal. Hier im Kochbuch steht:
Schneiden Sie zuerst den Käse klein,
schneiden Sie dann die Tomaten
und den Schinken in Würfel,
legen Sie alles auf die Pizza
und schieben Sie die Pizza für 20
Minuten bei 180 Grad in den Ofen.
- Okay.
- Meine Schwester kann sehr gut
kochen und backen.
Ich leider nicht.
- Ich auch nicht.
Aber Pizza backen ist leicht!
- Ja.
- Guten Appetit.